foreign
oh wait I know this one you are
if I ask you to do a press conference do
the press conference okay
I'm sorry I realize it was a big deal
so you just didn't do it
is that the plan for the rest of your
life
you're just gonna walk away from
everything a second it isn't fun or easy
what do you want Roy
hmm
what do you really want
I just won't be left alone oh
Roy you want way more than that you're
just so convinced that you don't deserve
anything good in your life that you'd
rather eat a bowl of soup and then
complain about the portions
get out of your own way man because this
whole Woo is moving thing you've got
going on is just
ponderous
[Music]
is that old
yeah that's it
[Music]
for now
foreign
[Music]